Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
the boys season four dropped their first Look teaser
with a couple scenes that will break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel
I'm doing videos for all the episodes,
just like previous seasons.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. They confirmed
that Season 4
is going to pick up days after the Gen V finale,
so I'll link that video at the end of this.
If you haven't seen the Gen V episodes yet,
I also did episode videos for all those.
So a lot of plot elements for that
will carry over into season four, most notably Victoria
Neuman's Compound V superhero virus
that she stole at the end of that
they actually legit released one of those
funny In-Universe Coleman
promos for that TV show of his Cameron's
TV show about Gen V season
two Tragedy on campus for good
ole King students went on a brutal murder spree.
Many more undoubtedly would have been killed
had it not been for the new Guardians
of the Dolphin, Pete Dunlap and Sam Reardon.
I'm trying to save you.
I want to be a hero to all.
Americans are safer with heroes
like Sam and Kate protecting us, our values
and our way of life.
the whole idea is that they're calling season
two sophomore year.
So the whole idea is that the college will continue
even if the Scooby Gang they're being kept in that
deep, dark hole by Vought, y'know, turning into
more of the boys universe version of the suicide Squad.
but just starting with these new boys
Season four scenes.
This scene is of homelander at a rally
and based on the butcher teaser,
this actually looks like it's them
winning the election.
Victoria Neuman and Robert Singer winning the election
in superheroes, getting into the White House.
the look on Homelander's face basically
makes it seem like he feels metaphorically invincible.
Like literally he's meant to feel invincible
because as far as we know, there's
nothing on the planet that could actually hurt him
in a really dangerous kind of way.
Like people have gotten close to it.
They made it seem like they could potentially hurt him,
but he's never really been hurt.
Like, for instance, maybe shove the pencil in his ear.
He's already healed that damage.
Like that's how quickly he heals.
maybe, maybe Victoria Neuman's compound
virus will be able to affect him in some way,
but I don't think that it will be.
I think that's the whole idea.
Like they want to make it seem like it's dangerous to
all the superheroes, but he's meant to be so powerful
that it won't affect him,
at least affect him in the same way.
So he'll basically be like,
Fine, there's nothing you can do to stop me.
Like you tried to out me as this terrible person
with the video of the plane.
but there's really crazy really hardcore fan base
that he developed around himself.
Basically will love him
no matter what crazy stuff that he does.
they also tease that a little bit during Jedi
with Victoria Neuman's storyline
where she was talking about Homelander's
potential trial during season four.
They'll address that in some way too.
But like I said, I do not think that he's actually
going to go to prison or anything like that.
if you remember Batman v Superman
where he addressed the council
like the Congress, basically
you have to imagine the boys universe version of that.
Like he would probably entertain
the idea of doing that briefly.
But there's no way, no way
he would ever let anybody ever take him to prison.
he would lose it way before that.
And I think the idea in the boys universe
is that the mob that supports him would actually riot
before that happened.
Either They have released a couple in universe
sort of parody teaser trailer videos
This is one of those videos.
Good morning, everyone. I'm Ashley Barrett.
Coming to you with an important update on behalf
of our greatest hero and our most loving father.
In the coming months, Homelander will stand trial for
saving his son from a vicious starlight loving thug.
An act of heroism.
Now somehow being branded a murder
make no mistake, Vought and its shareholders
stand fully behind Homelander, and this will in no way
impact his status as captain of the Seven.
We have complete faith in the American legal system
to get things right, like it always does.
For now, keep him and Ryan in your thoughts
and in your prayers
and be sure to post with hashtag home free.
So he can see your support.
But this is obviously them just joking about
what happened
at the end of season three with Homelander
and killing that dude that threw the can't.
Ryan the other part of the joke here is that
Ashley is doing her very best.
Stan Edgar trying to spin the news
towards the benefit of Vought in general,
and Homelander bravely trying to protect his son, Ryan,
against that vicious Starlight supporter.
all the thoughts and prayers, jokes
and then just the idea that they're not
going to change anything of their day to day
because of what happened with Homelander.
is a bit of an evolution of what happened
during the events of season
three, where Homelander
just completely lost it on live broadcast news,
but it wound up making him
way more appealing to his base and way less appealing
to just a general audience they've had this runner
during the boys seasons about the approval ratings
that each of the different superheroes
have, like the higher
the approval ratings that they have amongst the public,
the more money they earn from endorsements,
from the products that they try to sell. Basically.
which is the way that Homelander
sort of measured how much people loved him.
And that's what he wanted. Like
he wanted people to love him.
so he's always obsessed with his quote
unquote, poll numbers in the public.
And that's
what happened after his big rant earning season three.
that spun into
an evolution of the whole idea
that he can do anything that he wants.
But now he actually kind of starts to believe it
previously,
the idea that he was just kind of saying
that to himself, I don't think he actually believed it.
He was slowly going crazier and crazier,
but now he's into like
full blown crazy territory
trying to drink his own Kool-Aid.
they also made it seem like he had this weird moon
night thing going on where he had this completely
alternate persona that he developed as a child
to help him survive just because of what it was like
growing up inside that special room, quote unquote,
that they kept him in.
remember when we got put in the bad room?
I got us through that. the butcher teaser.
Did they release?
Seems like him standing around
in the aftermath of this election night party
with his side, Basically,
like Victoria Neuman gets into office?
I see the other side.
Technically, Homelander
doesn't really like Victoria Neuman,
But the whole idea is that she used to be doing this.
Like this whole campaign push
was to get Vought superheroes in the White House
to get control of the White House.
she kind of went rogue on the plan at the end, like she
made an alliance with Homelander against Stan Edgar.
so even though they don't really like each other,
they made an alliance temporarily
so that she can win the White House.
I think the whole idea that you're going to try to use
this compound be superhero virus
to get out from under his thumb,
so to speak, like somehow break away from Homelander
but even though she's sold out Stan Edgar
during season three, she did say to all the kids here
in the rally that she was going to create a position
for superheroes inside the government
to give them some sort of vote, some sort of say
And that's still basically what Stan Edgar's
original plan was, to have superheroes
basically in the government to take over the government
some of the other homelander scenes at the end of Gen
V were meant to set up.
The beginning of season four, like I said, is
going to take place like days after the end of the Gen
V finale,
basically him cleaning up that mess at the university.
But I'm wondering if any of the Gen V characters
will show up during the boys season four.
Like there's already so much going on, so we might not
see most of them until Gen V season two.
The boys showrunner also said that the show
is probably going to go way,
way beyond his original plan for five seasons.
So I'm expecting like seven seasons of the boys
now that should give you an idea of where
to theory craft
about how they're going to end the season.
Like even though we're now
sort of in like the end of the boys original comic book
storyline, like them making it into the White House
feels like the very end of that story.
it sounds like the TV
show is going to go way past that.
So the ending will be very different.
there are couple new characters
that we've learned about.
I already talked about Tech Night during my Gen V
episodes.
He's still alive, still loving all the holes
that he can find, sticking it in every single hole
that he can get his hands on.
We know that Jeffrey Dean
Morgan is going to be playing a brand new character.
He's working with Butcher here.
So I'm guessing that he's part of the government
or part of some black ops agency,
and that's how he gets into the story.
in we legit also learned about them doing the Boys
Universe version of Spider-Man.
That's right.
They have a Spider-Man character in the boys universe.
His name is Webb Weaver.
Yet do picture like a version of Bully Maguire,
Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man going for.
There's like, the worst person you could possibly
imagine that has powers just like Spider-Man.
I can already picture all the jokes that they'll make
about his organic webbing and which holes that
that actually comes out of
the weird thing about the Boys Universe
version of Spider-Man is that he's only featured
briefly on the cover of The Boys.
Dear Becky Issues.
It was the very final issue.
The original Boys
comic book by Garth Ennis is meant to tell the story
of what happens to Hughie and Starlight, like 12 years
after the events of the main story with Butcher
and the Boys versus Homelander, the Seven and Vought.
Webb, we've heard this boys
version of Spider-Man is featured on a cover
of one of these Dear Becky issues, and it's
meant to be an homage to the classic Marvel Amazing
Spider-Man issue number 316,
where Venom is taking out Spider-Man,
except in this case is Hughie
with his compound V powers taking out Webb Weaver.
And the other difference with Hughie in the comics
is that he gets compound V powers that are permanent
in in the TV show
he just had the temporary compound v powers
zoom in enhanced notice
that his Spider-Man costume on the cover here
looks about as Spider-Man
like as you can get without getting sued by Marvel.
Remember, this was published a long time ago too.
But there's another image of him
that looks way more Spider-Man like here.
the funny thing, though, is that Webb
Weaver is only mentioned briefly in the actual boys
story, like he's a relatively minor character
that you don't really see that much of that.
There's a point earlier in the Boys
main storyline where Butcher goes to the legend
to find a Compound V superhero that's big enough
that will convince Malory to fund the boys team.
So this is happening way
before the events of the series
and the legend character
who's meant to be a parody of Stan Lee,
who just knows everything, has information
on all these different superheroes.
he also kind of
looks like J. Jonah Jameson in this scene.
The way he talks about Webb, Weaver suggests
that Butcher take down
where we were there, Spider-Man,
who they also call the hipster
it. That's about
all you hear or see of their version of Spider-Man.
You can see Gardena is trying
not to get sued by Marvel,
but clearly making a bunch of Spider-Man parodies
and jokes.
all the boys characters are meant to be parodies
of Marvel and DC comic book characters
Hopefully because they dropped these teasers,
that means they're going to drop a much bigger trailer
in the next couple of weeks and hopefully
the strike stuff gets figured out pretty soon too.
my Fall Loki Season two Finale Video We'll post Friday
My Marvel's
Post-Credits Scene Video
Invincible Season two Episode two Videos.
After that, there's a bunch of big stuff coming up,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that Click here for that Loki Season
2 Episode 6 Finale video after the link.
As soon as I post that and click here for my boys.
Gen V Episode 8 Finale Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!